le commissaire européen michel barnier
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes avec nous alors qu'une lutte est
engagée elle met aux prises les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de l'union qui
à la tête de la commission bruxelles ça
ne va pas de soi apparemment malgré le
résultat de l'élection parlement
européen au risque donc de renforcer
l'image de démocratie hors sol que
renvoie trop souvent l'union européenne
comme vous l'écrivez d'ailleurs dans ce
livre michel barny se reposer ou être
libre l'europe la france dans l'union
les réformes qui s'imposent à l'une et à
l'autre
nous allons en parler donc au cours de
ce prof par trois que vous propose
public sénat avec l' agence france
presse avec perrine tarneaud donc et
guillaume daudin en partenariat toujours
comme chaque semaine avec dailymotion
d'abord bien sûr la bataille de la
succession de josé manuel barroso avec
ce front anti juncker l'ancien premier
ministre luxembourgeois dont le parti
votre parti est arrivé vainqueur en tête
un des élections européennes alors
est-ce qu'on se dirige vers un déni de
démocratie
puis un processus qui est engagée c'est
jamais simple sauf que cette fois ci il
ya eu quelque chose de nouveau que nous
avons voulu les différents partis
politiques le parti populaire européen
qui regroupe tous les partis de
centre-droit gens suivent un des
vice-présidents le parti socialistes et
libéraux les verts et d'autres encore
pour dire aux citoyens vous allez
également participer au choix du présent
de la commission en plus des livres de
pierre répété pendant la campagne vient
on admet donc le résultat a eu lieu le
parti populaire est arrivée en tête très
clairement en tête nous avons je crois
dans le groupe parlementaire 31 sièges
de plus que le second parti le parti
socialiste européen est donc clairement
c'est la seule chose que je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui c'est conscient des
mois
je ne vais pas papa beaucoup plus le
parti populaire européen et son
animateur que nous ont présentés comme
tels
jean claude juncker ont la légitimité
pour être le pivot de la future grande
majorité de projet qui doit se
construire au parlement et s'agissant
jean claude juncker pour être le prénom
de la commission doit d'être nommé c'est
le choix maintenant des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement puisque c'est leur
responsabilité
il faut respecter les traités et c'est
le choix du parlement européen voilà je
ne peux pas dire quelle sera l'issue de
ces discussions mais c'est le processus
qui est engageant mais le processus il
est entravée aujourd'hui c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire par le premier
ministre britannique david cameron qui
fait barrage
et alors il faut le constater encore
aujourd'hui avec une langue et la merkel
qui est plutôt ambigu puisqu'elle lui
fait les yeux doux au premier ministre
britannique
non madame merkel que je connais bien
elle est soucieuse comme je le suis moi
même que tout le monde reste à bord que
le royaume uni qui est un des très
grands pays de l'union européenne qui
est tellement importante pour le marché
du qui attachent d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'importance au marché unique et qui est
aussi un élément clé un acteur clef
d'une future politique étrangère
européenne du futur politique de défense
européenne reste bien dans l'union vous
savez bien regarder les résultats au
royaume uni qu'il y à de fortes
tentations le parti you keep est arrivé
en tête de séparation et donc moi je
pense que si on se sépare et ce sera un
affaiblissement pour tout le monde donc
il faut faire attention à ça maintenant
il faut faire attention faut aller vers
un compromis qui pourrait exclure jean
claude juncker on vous comprend je vous
écouterai je vous écoute et l'épargné
dans la balance il y a la grande
bretagne qui reste dans l'union ou lyon
coeur la commission attend entre les
deux choix on vous confond le jeu vaut
il faut retenir la grande bourgeoisie
indique clairement mon souhait que je te
d'une cure sera choisi et je suis loyal
depuis le premier jour avec lui ce jour
là je m'en souviens précisément puisque
j'étais en compétition avec lui au sein
du parti populaire européen ait un débat
et un vote démocratique et secret je
fais 40 % des voix il a fait 60 % depuis
ce jour là je le soutiens avant
l'élection le jour d'élection est depuis
l'élection
je ne changerai pas de ligne qui est
celle de la loyauté je dis simplement
que jean claude juncker présent de la
commission le parlement européen les
autres commis
et doivent être attentifs à une question
qui n'est pas négligeable qui est celle
de l'unité les marché unique et de la
présence dont nous avons besoin de la
vendre deux royaumes mais est ce que
votre loyauté
monsieur juncker vous empêcherait demain
d'être vous pour la commission pour la
présidence de la commission le candidat
de compromis
mais ce n'est pas fort et pose la
question à mes mains je vous réponds que
je ne veux pas répondre à cette question
parce que je suis dans une phase est la
solution nous sommes dans un processus
où normalement
jean claude juncker à cette légitimité
le parti populaire européen lui même
pour éviter un blocage sur sa personne
par exemple david comme on dit c'est un
homme du passé pouvez me poser quatre
fois la question à vous l'avez déjà fait
trois fois je ne voudrais pas une autre
réponse et j'aimerais bien que plutôt
que de parler des personnes on parle
quand on parle du royaume uni sa
présence des raisons de sa présence ce
qu'il faudrait faire comme signe aux
citoyens britanniques est d'ailleurs
français sur l'excellent bureaucratie
bruxelles qui s'occupe de tout rien de
vrai qu'est ce tu as une nouvelle qu'on
l'imposé mais j'aimerais bien qu'on en
vienne à ça comme enfermé de
réglementation - une bureaucratie à
bruxelles et plus de poule à govou zenke
personnellement - pas très bonne presse
non plus à londres parce que vous avez
pris des mesures pour une plus grande
régulation financière dans l'union
dans vos fonctions à bruxelles j'ai pris
ces mesures avec le soutien de gens mais
ça s'appelait pas forcément la city
quand même j'ai fait tout cela avec la
city par contre elle et sans elle qu'est
ce que ça voudrait dire d'ailleurs de
faire une régulation financière après
cette crise terrible dont on n'a pas
fini de payer les conséquences et ya
tellement de gens qui souffrent en
europe contre les anglais contre la city
qui est la principale place financière
donc j'ai fait c'était mon choix toutes
ces régulations avec la city vont passer
l'essentiel au gré des circonstances des
événements qu'on évoque sur lesquels
vous ne voulez pas vous étendre à michel
barnier mais enfin si au gré des
circonstances vous redevenez un candidat
vous devenez un candidat crédible pour
succéder à monsieur barroso est ce que
vous craignez que françois hollande se
pose avoue franchement posez lui la
question c'est à lui de répondre c'est
sa responsabilité de nommer le
commissaire français comme c'était le
cas de ses prédécesseurs il le fera en
tenant compte de l'intérêt de l'europe
et de la place de la france dans
l'europe
franchement je ne vais pas répondre à
ces pages ensemble parce que vous ont
toutes leurs questions mais c'est celle
que je vous ai posé d'emblée
est ce que vous craignez que et bien
on soit face à un déni de démocratie en
europe demain la fin du mois de juin
avec la nomination le choix du
successeur de josé manuel barroso si ça
ne correspond pas à ce qu'on a dit aux
électeurs pendant toute la campagne et
alors que même les opposants de gauche
de votre parti disent ces unions
querelles qui arrive en tête c'est lui
qu'il faut choisir
oui parce qu'il réunit démocratie oui ou
non je ne souhaite pas que ce soit le
cas je souhaite franchement est un
risque qui que je souhaite franchement
que les deux institutions qui doivent
décider le conseil européen qui doit
faire une proposition comme le dit le
traité en tenant compte du résultat des
élections et le parlement qui doit
donner son investiture au moins par 3
175 voix le se mettent d'accord pour
choisir un candidat conformément au vote
des citoyens alors pour moi ce candidat
devrait être jean claude juncker voilà
ce que je peux vous dire je peux pas
dire autre chose
ce qui me paraît plus important quand on
regarde comment les français notamment
voté ou plutôt pourquoi beaucoup d'entre
60 % n'ont pas voté c'est qu'on parle
des politiques et ont changé alors vous
avez de thein sein devrait vous
intéresser à saré bas nous sommes
passionnés parfois réservé aux
propositions personnelles
il ya toute une série dans tous les
domaines michel berger même fait un
petit bouquin avant les élections et qui
vaut 11 euros 50 a pris citoyens les
droits de ce livre on t'as une
association qui s'occupe d'haïti et dans
le monde du pauzé présidente et donc
j'ai fait ce petit bouquin pour
participer au débat d'idées parce que ce
qui intéresse les gens de là des hommes
des femmes des postes c'est qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour pour tirer les leçons de
la crise qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
entendre les citoyens et répondent aux
calories
justement vous avez vous des solutions
que vous préconisez vous en avez assez
de voir l'union a présenté comme le bouc
émissaire de tous les maux de l'europe
et de la france en particulier françois
hollande a réagi en disant que l'europe
était illisible incompréhensible pour
les citoyens vous êtes d'accord là elle
est bien sûr difficile à comprendre les
complexes très elle est d'autant plus
complexe et lisible qu'on n'explique pas
oui donc il faut que les acteurs
politiques présents d'un public qui le
fait l'elysée qu'ils ne font pas assez
les dépôts européenne il ya un problème
de pédagogie le sud de l'état dit aussi
il faut arrêter l'europe s'occupe de
tout attendez celle de choses
différentes que l'europe soit illisibles
parce qu'elle est complexe c'est clair
on pourrait mettre plus de simplicité
d'unités j'ai proposé dans mon livre
un jour un président de l'union
européenne qui cumulerait y aurait une
personne au lieu de deux les fonctions
quand la commission parent déconseillera
coopérative de démocratie alors j'ai
proposé qu'ils aient une plus grande
lisibilité au titre de la sphère
financière et économique en ayant un
ministre européen des finances
après la complexité je prends une minute
pour l'expliquer elle est un peu la
condition d'une europe unie qui n'est
pas uniforme
nous ne sommes pas un état fédéral on
veut pas être en net afférent
mais il n'y a pas un peuple européen il
n'y a pas une nation européenne
il ya vingt-huit natio 28 peuple 28
états qu'ils fusionnent pas mais qui
mutualisent une partie de leur destin
leur souveraineté et de leur politique
pour être plus forts et pour être
respecté dans le monde
ça peut pas être simple si c'est simple
c'est uniforme
donc il faut expliquer à ceux qui nous
écoutent que la complexité de bruxelles
la commission européenne et ses
vingt-huit personnes qui constituent une
sorte de premiers ministres européens
tous ensemble le conseil des ministres
qu'elle de la chambre d etat parlement
européen qui la change rien c'est
forcément complexes il fait le temps de
la campagne pour ça oui c'était juste
mon 25e campagne qui doit déduire trois
petites semaines vous rattraper pas en
propre une semaine d'une campagne qui
d'ailleurs pas été qui était très
hexagonale au lendemain des élections
municipales 30 ans de silence
et voilà pourquoi je suis content de
vous parler aujourd'hui après l' après
l'élection parce que c'est maintenant le
temps du tout mais est-ce qu'il faut
réduire les compétences de l'union ça
c'est une mesure concrète
j'ai proposé dans le cadre de mon débat
au sein du rpt et hip hop l'ayant pas
une idée que je crois juste pour
l'avenir c'est ce qu'on appellerait en
anglais lui open added value review
c'est à dire une révision des
compétences et des politiques en partant
de leurs intérêts de leur valeur ajoutée
européenne
est-ce que telle compétence européenne
dans le traité sp telle politique a
encore ou n'a pas encore pourrait avoir
ou à trop ou n'a pas de valeur ajoutée
et en révisé à son ensemble de
compétences face à l'europe passoire une
réponse est d'accord à la question
britannique c'est aussi une question aux
français qui sont très nombreux se poser
des questions sur est ce que l'europe ne
s'occupe pas trop de tout et de
n'importe quoi
cette fuite en avant pas de frontières
pas de limite je pense que cette
révision que j'ai proposée serait est un
bon outil nord pas de retour avec un
vrai débat qu elle fasse à l'europe
passoire souvent dénoncé comme tel en
tous les cas ce qu'il faut suspendre
schengen il faut pas
de schengen il faut appliquer renforcer
schengen comment on peut imaginer par
rapport aux flux de ces immigrés souvent
utilisé d'ailleurs par des trafiquants
par des mafias qui utilisent la pauvreté
et la misère
on le voit avec ces bateaux comment vous
imaginez de répondre chacun chez soi
chacun pour soi ça laissait malte chypre
la grèce l'italie l'espagne tout seul
c'est une question européenne
il faut pas suspendu ni faut appliquer
renforcer chez que ce qu'avait proposé
nicolas sarkozy le jour du scrutin mais
on a commencé il avait déjà proposé il
ya 45 ans nous avons appliqué une
première erreur qui l'avait souhaité et
moi je souhaite qu'on applique schengen
on peut appeler ça schengen deux très
bien
schengen trois dimensions en tous les
cas on peut pas s'y rendre il faut gérer
en commun nos frontières créer un corps
de gardes frontières comme un cas une
force européenne je le dis dans mon
bouquin une force européenne de
protection civile pour être capable pas
seulement dans le cas de ces malheureux
qui sont dans des bateaux mais dans le
cas de catastrophes naturels
d'inondation les catastrophes nucléaires
de du nahd que certains industriels son
ami est capable répondre ensemble plus
de gens qui ont pour soi renforcer
schengen n'est pas le suspense est votre
point de vue paris est elle fondée a
menacé washington de vols encore de
frontières de suspendre les négociations
qui sont engagées sur le très
controversé traité transatlantique
et tout cela pour répondre à la menace
d'amendés record qui qui pourraient
viser la bbc paribas j'ai une réponse un
peu plus générale je rêvais déjà fait
quand tu la sphère ce nom de demain avec
l'espionnage américain qui ne doit pas
se faire qu il ne devrait pas se faire
entre alliés et entre amis j'ai quand on
a des problèmes comme ça avec des alliés
c'est une raison de plus pour discuter
papa de se tourner le dos je serais
tenté de dire la même chose maintenant
c'est cette affaire de la bnp bray c'est
à cause de cela oui que de telle ou
telle idée a été émise
moi je voudrais très prudent c'est a
fait un truc pas justice américaine elle
est très complexe
je compte tenu de l'ampleur de la bnp et
des risques je comprends que les autres
étaient françaises suivent ça
attentivement des autorités européennes
aussi nous vous suivons très
attentivement cette situation
la seule chose que je peux dire dans le
respect
l'indépendant de juristes américaine
c'est que nous souhaitons que ces
d'angle seront traités comme tous les
autres acteurs de manière équitable et
objective d'accord et on y voit des
amendes demandées quand même je ne
connais pas le détail de cette affaire
mais pénalité je souhaite que cette
affaire soit traitée de manière cette
banque de manière équitable les
objectifs ça vous le demander aux états
unis alors guillaume daudin de l' agence
france-presse va nous rejoindre
maintenant on va vous interrogez gilles
bernier sur la france malade de l'europe
bien sûr avec ses piètres performances
économiques et puis la place de numéro
un qui est occupé désormais à l'issue de
ce scrutin européen par le front
national d'abord donc le rappel de
quelques données clés par marie brémaud
la france rappelé à l'ordre par
bruxelles
c'était il ya trois mois la commission
européenne ce a left ait des dérapages
budgétaires
avec des prévisions de déficit à 4% du
produit intérieur brut
paris reste bien loin de l'objectif fixé
à 3,6 pour cent pour 2014
dans le cas français on reste sur les
objectifs mais souvent on demande une
dérogation pour ce qui est des échéances
aujourd'hui la france est devenue champ
du tout un problème pour l'europe un
problème pour elle même d'abord il est
vrai que la france accumule les mauvais
résultats et ce depuis plusieurs années
en matière de déficit en matière de
croissance en matière de compétitivité
la france entre dans le peloton de queue
de l'union européenne
comment se fait il que c'est en france
que le taux d'impôt sur les bénéfices
des sociétés le plus élevé 38 % alors
que d'autres pays sont entre 15 et 20%
comment se fait-il que ce soit en france
que les prélèvements sur les salaires
les contributions sociales sont les plus
élevés de tous les pays de l'union
européenne etc ainsi on est disqualifié
en quelque sorte la compétitivité du
travail en france mais la france est
elle un pays réformable à l'heure où ses
voisins du sud comme l'espagne l'italie
ou le portugal met en oeuvre des mesures
drastiques qu'impopulaires paris
apparaît bien souvent réfractaires au
changement
c'est un pays qui est vu comme en
difficulté par les autres et quand je
dis en difficulté c'est difficulté à
s'extraire un peu du passé dans le fond
le problème de la france c'est ça c'est
cette difficulté à quitter un peu la
nostalgie des trente glorieuses et
devenir un pays
qui se modernise y compris en touchant
en touchant à ski la plus fondamentale
c'est à dire aussi en réformant le
social mais avec le pacte de
responsabilité
le gouvernement français semble emprunté
le bon chemin bruxelles s'en félicite
mais maintient la pression sur paris
quant à son application voilà guillaume
daudin de l'afp est avec nous michel
barnier aux questions commissaire
européen sur la france
le pacte de responsabilité sur les rails
mais ce matin était publié un appel
d'une centaine de députés ps avec des
contre propositions de projet de loi de
finances rectificative
donc ils demandent moins d'argent pour
les entreprises et en même temps plus
d'argent pour le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages l'investissement public où les
emplois plus employé qu'est ce que vous
dites au gouvernement vous leur dites de
tenir bon ou d'écouter les frondeurs du
coup tu franchement de mener en des pas
comme commissaire au talent de venir
mais les relations entre la majorité
telle ou telle partie du groupe
socialiste et le gouvernement vous avez
sur les réformes
c'était pas tout à fait la question je
je je pense que le moment où nous sommes
à un moment de vérité et où il va
falloir que tout le monde fasse preuve
de courage politique
les députés socialistes le gouvernement
qui me paraît aller dans la bonne
direction et peut-être aussi si on
permettait de venir l'opposition parce
que s'il ya des mesures en application
du plan valls qui vont dans la bonne
direction je pense que l'opposition
devrait aller voter
ça m'est arrivé des députés d'opposition
dans france et de voter des mesures
proposées par le gouvernement et
réciproquement aggrave le pas que de
responsabilité vous voulez voter le
voteriez il y à des mesures il faut voir
le contenu
s'agissant de la baisse des charges des
impôts sur les entreprises qui sont
tellement pénalisé qu'elle ne bouge plus
e
il faut libérer que des voix jeune j'ai
été élu pendant 17 ans d'un conseil
général en savoie jeu j'étais toujours à
grenoble pour rencontrer des chefs
d'entreprise dans le domaine de
l'innovation y ait une énergie contenue
il ya une formidable capacité
d'initiative dans ce pays d'innovation
d'investissement mais qui contenu qui
est bloqué il faut libérer et c'est pour
ça que je pense de tout à l'heure on
parlait d
j'ai que si on libère en appliquant les
mesures de monsieur valls en août en
allant plus loin d'ailleurs on libère
cette capacité là on va retrouver la
cour si je comprends bien ce que vous
dites
françois hollande a évolué depuis le
début de son quinquennat il va plutôt
dans le bon sens c'est sa maudite i je
dis simplement qu'il a lui-même toujours
dit qu'il respecterait les fameux
critères de déficit qui ça ne vient pas
fait pour faire plaisir à bruxelles
franchement bien sûr il ya bien quand on
dirait un règlement de copropriété de la
zone euro on n'a pas d'ailleurs
suffisamment respectée dans le passé
c'est pour ça qu'on a été dans cette
crise en plus de la crise financière il
faut respecter ce règlement de
copropriété vis-à-vis des autres mais
c'est pas pour faire plaisir à bruxelles
ses vis-à-vis des jeunes français qu'est
ce que ça veut dire de continuer à tirer
des chèques en blanc en bois sur les
générations futures les impôts d'eau
gelée les emprunts d'aujourd'hui les
dettes certains disent au groupe
socialiste faisait encore plus de dette
ont fait pas de la croissance avec des
dettes les dettes d'aujourd'hui ce sont
des impôts pour nous pour nos enfants
ça suffit vous savez quand on paye de
charge de la dette
le service de la dette coûte 46
milliards chaque année au budget de la
france plus que le budget de l'éducation
nationale
c'est pas normal mais quand un reproche
un peu à la commission européenne que
finalement il n'y aurait qu'une seule
voie ça serait la réduction des dépenses
publiques pour être poli l'austérité
pour c'est pas la même chose et on peut
parler d'austérité dans certains pays et
sans doute at-elle été trop brutale et
j'ai plaidé en a même pour qu'on
différencie les niveaux des efforts dans
le temps et pour certains pays nous
faisons ça me permet à culpa par rapport
à ce qui était décidé pour l'europe du
sud probablement dans certains pays le
niveau d'effort a été trop brutale
mais nous nous avons compris cela est
maintenant différent c'est vers ces pays
font de très gros efforts et tous sont
en train de sortir de deux de la plus
grande difficulté y compris la grèce le
portugal l'espagne sont attend cela non
franchement c'est la bonne gestion
vis-à-vis des générations futures
oh la la france est pleine de
rhumatismes elle est trop conservatrices
et les trop centralisée il faut libérer
ce pays et les regarder pourquoi ça
marche mieux chez les autres qui sont
également dans la zone euro pourquoi ça
marche mieux en allemagne je dis pas
qu'il faut tout copier mais en allemand
que vous avez des entreprises
l'entrepreneuriat régional qui est
soutenu par les banques et familiale
vous avez une culture de stabilité
budgétaire ont fait des dépenses ont
fait des en premier pour l'avenir pas
pour payer le fonctionnement on a le
dialogue social
notre pays franchement est incapable
nana c'est le modèle allemand qui est
peut-être la bonne voie je pense qu'il y
a il comprit le domaine de la formation
de l'alternance de bonnes idées à
prendre chez les autres y compris dans
les pays leur 10 mai et vous avez
commencé une sorte de mea culpa et
souvent dans cette troïka donc union
européenne-banque centrale un commission
européenne banque centrale et et fonds
monétaire international- on a dit que la
bbl la commission européenne était un
peu les ayatollahs l'austérité c'était
ce qui était le plus engagé dans la voie
de l'austérité je ne crois pas qu'il y
ait des gens plus dur que nous aurons eu
des décisions prises à trois et
probablement de drôle dans l'urgence le
dos au mur au début de cette crise qui
était absolument inouïe parce que je
rappelle que la crise financière qui est
venu des états unis du comportement
irresponsable de certaines banquier de
certaines banques qui sont truc tout
permis plutôt à qui on avait tout permis
à force de déréguler est venu impacter
une europe qui était faible jacques
delors d'ailleurs dit lui-même peut pas
voir l'union monétaire et la désunion
économique et plus en plus ça désigne
économique et la crise financiers on
avait des pays qui étaient noyés sous
les dettes comme la grèce et d'autres
donc on apprendre le mois dans l'urgence
pour trouver le bon chemin pour en
sortir
peut-être eu des problèmes d'ajustement
de niveau 2 les formes ouvertes en jeu
nous sommes nous sommes sur la bonne foi
rappelle la nécessité des efforts
budgétaires mais certains économistes
disent que leurs complexes par exemple
de 1%
la dépense publique et bien il ya une
baisse de croissance de 1% équivalente
alors il ya aussi des risques
ça dépend où vous fait peser la baisse à
vous ça dépend où il ya bien sûr helmand
vous voulez mauvaise bien sûr il ya de
bonnes et de mauvaises dettes il ya rien
endettement qui peut être comme l'avait
fait à l'époque françois fillon sur les
dépenses d'avenir la recherche
l'investissement et le gouvernement
actuel fait aussi de bons
investissements
il ya des investissements qui préparent
l'avenir mais faire payer le
fonctionnement de la france
d'aujourd'hui
papa part des impôts sur nos enfants je
trouve ces pages majeur
impôts mais certains partis en france
ont mis en cause la question l'euro ils
ont dit en france à cause de l'euro sur
lequel on n'a pas vraiment de pouvoir de
décision on est obligé de faire de la
dévaluation salariale pour être
compétitif j'imagine que vous pensez que
c'est pas forcément le problème le pot
et pourquoi ça se passe pas comme ça
chez les autres dans la zone euro
pourquoi l'allemagne n'a pas le même
problème
c'est bien la preuve que c'est pas
l'euro l'euro probablement est un peu
fort et d'ailleurs vous avez vu le
brillant la banque centrale européenne
ne se draguer son équipe prendre des
mesures très fortes pour pour répondre à
ce risque qui n'est pas encore là mais
qui peut se produire de déflation et moi
je fais confiance à la banque centrale
européenne qui joue son rôle et qui jeu
qui le joue bien mais regardez dans la
zone euro regardez d'où vient notre
déficit commercial il est dans la zone
euro où ils ont la même monnaie c'est
bien que ce n'est pas le problème la
monnaie le problème c'est notre manque
de compétitivité alors c'est parti vous
répondrais peut-être justement le
problème justement c'est pas l'euro pour
tous mais en tout cas l'euro pour la
france est au niveau de la france
peut-être que il faudrait en sortir
non il faut pas en sortir il faut il
faut pas se cacher sous la table et
faire la politique de l'autruche parce
qu'on on aura des problèmes encore plus
grave à régler et on sera tous seuls
pour les régler il faut faire
fonctionner leurs eaux faire confiance à
la banque centrale pour qu'ils aient le
bon niveau se préserver des dévaluations
entre nous vous vous imaginez qu'on
revienne aux dévaluations dans la même
zone européenne comme ça que moi j'ai
que l'échec est présent de la savoie
pendant 17 ans j'ai vu le les
conséquences des dévaluation de la lire
italienne juste de l'autre côté de la
montagne
d'un seul coup des centaines d'emplois
étaient détruites pas par la dévaluation
tokyo on a enfin de la stabilité
il faut gérer l'euro avec une économie
coordonnées on est en train de le faire
et puis il faut réformer la france il
faut diminuer les charges qui font du
mit les impôts il faut faire la
stabilité fiscale est administratrice et
100 d'entre vous amuser donc au courage
politique les dirigeants l'opposition et
puis les français également vous êtes de
passage avec nous aujourd'hui à paris
entre bruxelles et les états unis
vous êtes de passage à paris alors qu'il
ya une mobilisation des chauffeurs de
taxis et des cheminots des intermittents
du spectacle qui défendent leur statut
quand vous voyez ça que vous avez envie
de rire jeudi que le gouvernement je
vais pas me prononcer sur telle ou telle
réforme dont je n'ai pas la
responsabilité
je vois bien qu'il est difficile de
réformer la france mais il faut que le
gouvernement et de la ténacité et du
courage il c'est le moment et ça
explique aussi peut-être faiblesse de la
france cette absence de dialogue social
de dialogue politique l'absence de débat
regardez-la la campagne européenne dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure qui a été
tellement hexagonal est tellement courte
on sait si mal si peu parlé de l'europe
le dialogue social dans l'entreprise
dans les branches dans le pays
voilà une des clés du succès est loin
aussi on a parlé de ses difficultés de
la france finalement on veut parfois on
entend la france est donc l'homme malade
de l'union européenne et puis il ya eu
le résultat des deux derniers scrutins
et le fn a été placé en tête en france
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce score
c'est quelque chose je ne pense pas que
la france soit le malade là des
faiblesses elle a des faiblesses je
viens de les dire elles sont sérieuses
elles sont graves
il faut redresser ce pays et le faire
par le dialogue social et avec tous les
partenaires
mais je pense que c'est possible pour ne
pas mieux portants tous les cas on a une
faiblesse et c'est la faiblesse de la
france et la faiblesse de l'europe c'est
pour ça que c'est une leçon de cette
crise et que le problème de l'un devient
très vite prem de tout le monde donc il
faut corriger
et c'est pas des gens qui vont venir
fall trahis pas quand c'est nous qui
devons le faire alors qu'un score du
voilà du front national c'est aussi ont
été surpris parce que quand on parle si
peu et si mal de l'europe pendant vingt
ou trente ans quand il ya tant de
difficulté étant de peur qu'on dise à
terme la peur des autres l'immigration
qui est mal contrôlé quand il ya parfois
des déceptions l'égard d'une personne
politique quand il ya tellement de
chômage ait des gens qui souffrent on
l'a vu dans les banlieues parfois dans
les milieux ruraux voudrait toujours des
gens pour pour utiliser ça pour
exploiter cinq ans pour proposer il ya
eu cette dernière sortie de jean marie
le pen celui tienne il a parlé de la
fournée au sujet de l'artiste patrick
bruel est ce que vous pensez que il a sa
place au parlement européen
il y avait eu des appels par l'oms jégo
été élu et naturellement c'est pas très
neuf de la part de sur le pen que ces
dérapages si je puis dire c'est des
racistes ou antisémites que je trouve
absolument insupportable s'il ne
respecte pas la loi il faut que la loi
il sera condamné au terme de la loi mais
je trouve qu'il ya dans ce pays
tellement de tension tellement de
violence que le rôle des hommes
politiques quels qu'ils soient c'était
de ne pas rajouter un faux pas ne doit
pas être déçu de signer ce n'est pas la
loi qui luttent qui condamne dans kimi
sémitisme et la xénophobie
il doit être condamné les parties
prenantes de se retourner contre lui et
donc en france et une certaine vague
souverainiste on va dire en tout cas
d'un appel a déjà été condamnée
d'ailleurs comme vous le savez il ya un
appel à plus de souverainisme et parents
dans un dossier très précis le dossier
alsthom arnaud montebourg a pris un
décret pour élargir les secteurs
réservés de l'économie française
préservé par dans l'économie française
si vous pensez qu'il ait pris la bonne
décision que du point de vue de la
commission
je peux pas reprocher au gouvernement de
vouloir contrôler savoir qui achète quoi
en france
d'ailleurs les allemands les envies dans
des dispositifs comparables ya déjà dix
américains aussi est déjà un dispositif
qui existe en france qui le décret de
monsieur l'eau ce qui élargit le
gouvernement actuel nous sommes en train
de regarder s'il est conforme au traité
après la question de la politique
industrielle c'est pas le dos au mur en
urgence lorsqu'il a dit les entreprises
comme alstom est en difficulté qu'il
faut se demander s'il doit être associés
à general electric ou à siemens
moi je plaide pour qu'on ait une
véritable politique industrielle et dans
mon livre il ya tout un chapitre sur
tout un chapitre pourquoi parce que la
question c'est de la liberté des
européens comment reste libre comme un
souverain comment rester indépendant
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui face au
chili aux allemands de siemens ne
s'impose pas forcément quoi il faut
prendre la meilleure politique la
meilleure solution industrielle est
américaine mais encore une fois il faut
que les ministres de l'industrie des
plusieurs pays notamment français
allemand les industriels eux mêmes se
mettent autour de la table et voit quels
sont les secteurs stratégiques men
les technologiques et qu'il faut
préserver c'est pas de protectionniste
qui nous permettra de le faire
la bonne protection c'est pas le
protectionnisme la bonne protection
c'est l'investissement c'est la
recherche est solide raciste et n'aurait
pas pu justement investir dans alstom
pour essayer de le sortir de ce mauvais
lui peut-être qu'ils avaient imaginé en
s'y prenant un peu plus tôt une autre
solution plus européenne avec des
partenaires mais ça ça se réfléchit pas
le dos au mur dans l'urgence s'alléger
puisqu'on parle la liberté européen j'ai
un tableau que je montre souvent à ce
qui m'interroge qui est un tableau
d'ailleurs publié par monsieur cameron
je sais pas si on le voit là normalement
ils montrent tous les dix ans à partir
de maintenant les 4 les 10 pays les plus
importants du monde il ya quatre pays
européens en jaune
parmi les 10 puissance du monde
aujourd'hui seulement quatre sur 28 pays
et tous les dix ans il y en a un qui est
éjecté du tableau et quand est ce qu'on
espère la télé on disparaît en 2008
en 2050 pardon en 2050 on a bien lire
colonne algérie 8
il n'y a plus un seul pays européens la
suisse et la corée parents n'y sont pas
prêts portant ses des économies
performantes elles n'y sont pas encore
mais vous avez la chine l'inde les états
unis nous si on veut rester dans le
tableau si on veut rester à la table de
ceux qui décident plutôt que de subir et
de regarder il faut être ensemble
non c'est pour ça que la liberté
industrielle la liberté numérique la
liberté en termes de d'énergie la
dépendance énergétique la défense sont
des sujets où nous jouerons truc volonté
où il faut ensemble
merci guillaume et petite question david
cameron annoncé que l'union allait
s'attaquer aux abus de la liberté de
mouvement dans l'europe il dit ça contre
ceux qui perçoivent indûment c'est son
mot
les allocations des systèmes de
protection selon les pays vous êtes
d'accord avec cette démarche parce que
les lois européennes qui encadre cette
les abus des libertés
oui il ya des lois européennes notamment
la loi sur le détachement des
travailleurs la liberté de circulation
sont encadrés par des textes
il faut que ces textes et ça ils sont en
tournée ces textes aussi ça que monsieur
caméra devenir url on est là bas par
exemple prenons la question de leur
détachement des travailleurs vous avez
une loi qui est utile qui permet de dire
à des centaines de milliers de français
d'aller travailler dans votre pays
européens il faut que chez toi soit
respecté que vous êtes ne soit pas
synonyme de dumping social entreprise
qui la détourne soit condamné il n'y a
pas de complaisance avoir à coeur gens
allaient perrine tarneaud arrive
maintenant on va évoquer vos ambitions
européennes nationales aussi régional
peut être aussi vous allez nous dire ça
dans un instant et pour françois
hollande en tous les cas votre
succession à bruxelles pourrait être un
casse tête sauf à penser qu'ils
s'amusent a encouragé plusieurs
ambitions rivales samia de sheer sous
mandat n'est pas encore achevé mais déjà
la bataille pour sa succession est
engagé après cinq ans au poste de
commissaire européen pour la france
michel barnier quittera son poste en
novembre
d'ici quelques semaines françois
hollande proposera donc au conseil
européen le candidat de son choix parmi
les socialistes plusieurs personnalités
ont déjà annoncé être intéressé par le
poste
mais on cite surtout deux noms la
députée elisabeth guigou forte de son
expérience européenne face à pierre
moscovici qui semble très confiant pour
ne pas vous cacher un secret c'est
quelque chose dont nous parlions déjà
avec françois hollande
depuis plusieurs mois avant même ce
remaniement
moi je vois ça non pas comme un lot de
consolation mais comme un projet comme
quelque chose qui est pour moi une façon
de poursuivre une action publique moins
médiatique la députée européenne
pervenche berès est elle aussi dans la
course
enfin il se murmure que jean marc
ayrault vre devenu député après son
passage à matignon se verrait bien lui
aussi à bruxelles je pense que c'est une
candidature un peu fantaisistes même si
effectivement il parle allemand il n'a
pas du tout un passé de européens malgré
tout les commissaires qu'on a envoyé
à bruxelles en tout cas michel barnier
il avait un vrai passé d'européens il
avait manifesté son intérêt pierre
moscovici a manifesté son intérêt alors
à bruxelles on n'attend pas forcément
pierre moscovici
parce qu' il a pu une réputation de
dilettante on se dit que le jeudi soir
et ont envie de rentrer chez lui et de
pas forcément s'investir énormément
contrairement par exemple à une
pervenche berès mais pour l'instant
personne ne se risque à avancer le nom
d'un réel favori françois hollande a la
réputation de décider seul et au dernier
moment
son choix est d'autant plus compliquée
que la france est aujourd'hui affaiblie
face à bruxelles nous sommes à la veille
et bien de subir des condamnations voir
au delà des remontrances des pénalités
de la part de la commission européenne
pour non respect de nos engagements
financiers de quatre noms que vous venez
de me citer bas ils sont directement
liées justement à l'état aujourd'hui de
déficit économique je n'irai crucial de
notre pays
autre inconnue le portefeuille qui
reviendra à la france pierre moscovici
viserait un poste économique tandis
qu'elisabeth guigou se verrait bien en
chef de la diplomatie européenne
ah bah écoutez votre place fait rêver
beaucoup de monde
question toujours commissaires européens
qui ont quelques mois encore lui qui
franchement je trouve ce débat à peu ce
réaliste mais mais nous sommes à
fonctionner qui va quand même des
ambitions
nous sommes fin j'ai rarement vu dans le
passé que les gens faisaient campagne
donc ça pour devenir commissaire
européen mais mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que nous sommes en fonction
jusqu'au mois d'octobre et ce temps doit
être utile c'est un temps de travail moi
j'ai plein de textes que le parlement
qui vient d'être renouvelée va à nouveau
examinée dès le mois de juillet sur la
régulation financière sur le contrôle
des bains rangements partir plus tôt non
plus jusqu'au bout et je perds contre
d'ambition ça manifester alors je vais
je donc france et bien manifesté son
intérêt
bien sûr toucher et et je suis encouragé
à parler encore plus d'europe que je
sais que c'est pas moi qu'il faut
demander de faire des commentaires
bien sûr mais je ne sais tu nous dire
quel est le portrait robot idéal futur
comme ça vous mettez des conditions dans
votre livre
bon pour le poste les posteurs comme ça
à voiron une expérience sur opel oui oui
franchement une conviction son mandat il
faut être une conviction une compétence
il faut être respecté par les autres et
puis il faut être aussi patriote et
européen parce que commissaire européen
il prête serment je le dire ceux qui
nous écoutent qu'ils ne savent peut-être
pas première chose qu'on fait on prête
serment ce qui est inhabituel pour un
homme politique français devant la
justice en séance plénière solennelle
d'être indépendant des intérêts privés
ce qui est la moindre des choses et des
intérêts nationaux dont je suis pas de
représentant de la france
je participe avec mes collègues à la
construction d' intérêt général européen
mais j'ai aussi un devoir que j'assume
par exemple on répondra à vos questions
d'explication dans mon pays dans ma
longue aujourd'hui je peux je pense que
c'est aussi ça on attend deux
commissions paix qui soit patriote et
européen
oui dont vous allez panneaux cité deux
noms celui qui serait le mieux placé
pour lui on se souvient ainsi dénoncé le
choix du présent la république le moment
venu je recommande qu'on respecte ce
choix et on respecte sa décision
mais ce que vous craignez par exemple
que cette nomination dépendent d'un
choix politique trop nationale peut-être
il ya toujours un aspect politique mais
moi je fais confiance au président
république comme j'ai pu faire confiance
à nicolas sarkozy quand il va proposer
ou à jacques chirac puisque j'ai déjà
été commis comme ceux européen en accord
d'ailleurs entre jacques chirac et
lionel jospin à l'époque nous étions
deux commissaires français pascal lamy
est mois pour faire un choix qui soit
conforme à la vision française de
l'europe c'est ça dont il s'agit a
l'intérêt de l'europe
donc vous l'avez dit vous êtes
commissaire européen encore jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'automne prochain et après est
ce que vous avez envie de renouer avec
la politique nationale et après si je
suis dans la commission ne suis pas
utile à bruxelles on y revient alors
reviendrait dans mon pays qu'il est pas
seulement le mien que vous n'avez
je reverrai sans doute sur le terrain
parce que moi j'ai besoin de la
confiance des gens j'ai besoin de
vérifier le soutien populaire voilà ce
que je peux dire
alors bien sûr on la joue rhône alpes
qui est ma région
là où j'ai mes racines il prétend dire
cette nuit j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de
temps de toute façon à la hauteur de mon
mandat pour aller à la rencontre des
gens pour les écouter pour pour pour
reprendre contact dont je vais prendre
ce temps des jugements ces jeunes
travaux présentés donc j'annoncerai les
choses quand j'aurai pris ce temps de la
consultation de la concertation dit
quand même que effectivement c'était
changerait 7 et sciences régionale de le
dire je garde comme ça quand j'avais
vingt deux ans le jour ma première
élection comme le suffrage universel
comme conseiller général de bourg saint
maurice en haute tarentaise
je garde exactement la même capacité d'
enthousiasme et la capacité
d'indignation qui devrait être celle de
tout en politique tant que j'ai ça le
changera je veux rester dans le débat
politique j'ai peut-être les choses à
apporter y compris par rapport à ce que
j'ai appris ou compris des enjeux
européens et mondiaux
et donc je vais participer à ce débat et
je viendrai chercher la confiance des
gens alors voilà vous l'annoncer vous
irez chercher la confiance à vos appels
solliciter le suffrage des électeurs
qu'on voit là c'est une confiance les
confères rapprocher de la région rhône
alpes et l'auvergne ça vous semble une
bonne idée
je viens de comprendre qu'il est logique
de tout ça je connais bien l'auvergne
j'ai beaucoup travaillé que les gens de
l'ouvert notamment de la révision de la
politique agricole commune pour cette
petite plus juste à l'égard des éleveurs
et qu'elle soit mieux comprise par tout
le monde
c'est une grande région j'ai besoin de
comprendre la logique est quelque part
dans cette réforme que je trouve du type
d'incident son objectif de réduire le
nombre des régions de réduire les frais
de fonctionnement dans ce sens deux
villes d'europe
leur voisine ailleurs on peut le
critiquer critiquer l'action les
enquêtes affaiblissement des nations
avec ses grandes séquences quelque part
là la réforme qui était précédé par
présenté par le présent gouvernement
consistait à prendre les choses dans
l'autre sens fusionner progressivement
les conseillers vrai que les régions
sans changer la taille des régions
j'ai besoin de comprendre où va se
trouver le lieu de solidarité
territoriale parce que les régions
rurales et même parfois les joues robben
est longue
un endroit de solidarité qui étaient
élus du conseil général
si on doit supprimer un jour le conseil
général dans de très grandes régions
j'ai peur qu'il manque quelque chose au
milieu pour pour cette solidarité donc
voilà mais je vais essayer de comprendre
où est la logique de ce rapprochement et
comment comment de tels grande région
peuvent être aussi utile à la solidarité
des territoires miel vins et vous avez
été très critique contre la campagne
européenne de l'ump depuis il ya eu la
ferme bygmalion il ya eu la démission de
tous les partis dont l'ump mais de l'ump
de madère fille il ya eu dans ma propre
famille des opinions diverses et musoni
50 pas émérite il est beau jean françois
copé avait exprimé une ligne a été celle
d'alain lamassoure de tous les candidats
dans les territoires mais mais quelque
part il ya eu pas mal de perturbations
et d'henri guaino la division et je
pense que c'est le moment dans la
difficulté se trouve l'ump est
privilégiée après la sérénité qui doit
revenir de privilégier le débat d'idées
par rapport aux autres personnes
mais alors qui justement pour incarner
ce débat d'idées qui pour rassurer
apaiser au sein de l'ump est ce que
c'est nicolas sarkozy qui va pouvoir
sauver le parti insiste je n'émettrai
manassé est lui qui veut dire à ce à
quoi il est prêt j'ai été son ministre
je le connais bien je pense depuis
longtemps que son énergie son expérience
sont utiles à la france et devront être
utile ça maintenant
maintenant c'est le moment